What is the best way to get rid of cellulite?
The notice I've had more cellulite on my thighs and the rear,
even over my quadriceps, which were always solid.
I asked because we're working to prevent estrogen dominance.
I know the body stores estrogen here.
So I only need a little vein.
So I have only due a little vein,
but mostly concerned with story too much estrogen.
In case you don't remember who asked,
I have had ER positive breast cancer, which are 50 chisps.
So I'm happy about that coming up.
Yeah, there is actually some issues in
trying to lose fat too quickly because you made a comment,
which is true.
And fat cells is where you store most of your toxins
and certainly excess hormones.
So excess hormones are stored in fat cells.
Oxins are stored in fat cells.
They are the first cell line to pick up toxins and store toxins
in hormones.
And the issue has been when people lose weight quite quickly.
They liberate a lot of toxins.
And they can make themselves quite ill.
I don't think that's what you're asking you're asking
is to how to help fully lose that cellulite, lose that weight.
Well, if I were really good at knowing how
to do that really super easily, I'd be very wealthy.
There's a lot of places out there that tell you
that they're really good at it, you know, take your money.
Bottom light is just exercise.
And of course, there's reasons why, of course,
hold more weight and have a more difficult time losing weight.
That gets into the different hormones,
the two-terry, the thyroid, and the adrenal gland,
particularly the thyroid gland.
Of course, it has no thyroid.
It's even harder than the lose weight.
They seem to have weighed on.
Also, there's an issue with leptin and braline,
which has to do with your feeling of fullness
and your feeling of hunger with people who gain extra weight.
But as far as just losing that extra cellulite,
that extra fat that we all tend to gain as we get older,
yeah, there is no real secret to that.
So it's basically, you know, getting exercise,
trying to keep your exercise levels up there
where you're burning your calories that you're taking
in as best as you can.
Of course, everybody is different.
If you've been anywhere, you're at with your cancer.
There's also genetic factors that play into this too.
Some people are going to gain weight more easily than others.
Certainly, you don't want to be in a state of
for kexia or something like that, trying to, you know,
you want your best.
So I don't have any secret answers to that.
One more time.